a flood of support from latinos here
pushed the president to victory in
florida
i like everything how he thinks how he
do
you know i think he'll write i think
he's good good people for the
community and why don't you like joe
biden
don't buy the for me it's too weak
with cuban americans in particular
donald trump experienced a mini red wave
they liked his message they felt that he
listened to them
[Applause]
these local election celebrations prove
the president's popularity
it's estimated around 55 percent of
florida's cuban-american vote
went to trump
[Music]
many residents settled here in little
havana after escaping communist regimes
jose santana's family fled here when he
was three
tom is a little more stronger i believe
there's stronger view
towards uh
dictators he's trying to end communism
around
the country which are our neighbor you
see the three stripes
basically it's a cuban flag across the
street johnny big papa karducha
is even clearer they think that joe
biden is a socialism
trump's false portrayal of joe biden as
a left-wing extremist has
seeped in here eroding trust in
democrats
sowing doubt in the election process
donald trump is saying that fraud could
have been involved in the election he
might take it all the way to the supreme
court would you back him to the end
yes i would to the supreme court to the
poutine court you know what if we're
going to go to supreme court apollo
could take another
uh i don't know maybe december
who knows but you'll fight with him yeah
yeah yeah
a legal challenge by donald trump could
still
spark a popular one his base here and
across the country
is clear it's got his back siobhan
robbins
sky news florida